how is your your good pal you talk about
them all the time and you guys have been
buddies forever and I'm talking about
mr. Jason Bateman you guys we have there
he is
wow talk about a lukewarm reception this
guy new nickname might be Luke no he's
pretty he's pretty good I guess
what do you mean you guess I don't know
I try he's like he's our ding ding ding
I'm like what what do you want this
guy's texting me up and hitting me up
all the time I'll tell you a funny story
and this very relatable I got a new car
very fancy car yeah a little while ago
German yeah and rhymes with or SH yeah
[Music]
relatable so yeah so anyway so years ago
Jason was driving around in a in a
similar car his was a Porsche yeah yeah
and so he gave me a ride to the airport
which I still don't know why he was
giving me a ride to the airport but I
put it this way he's got a lot of time
on his hands but he give me a ride and
we're driving this is a true story
as we're driving he goes does this some
this car kind of make me look like an
[ __ ]
and I said yeah it does yeah so it was
like not long after that he got rid of
it just because you said I don't know if
we got rid of different but he did kind
of he was like yeah I don't think it's a
it's kind of Dicky or whatever so years
later I told him I said you know I just
ordered this new car portion he goes you
told me I looked like an [ __ ] driving
I go you did
I your friend jason bateman I think had
some good luck or recently or some good
fortune he became the voice of Hyundai
he is the voice of Hyundai yeah which is
good good for him it's a good brand for
him as you know for many years I mean I
got that new Kabaeva
i like automobiles but i like i like a
nice north american automobile i happen
to drive a GMC yukon XL denali you are
not only you are also the voice i am the
voice of GMC trucks and ahead I hear you
all the time I watch ads and every time
a GMC truck comes on we are professional
grade and the thing is the thing is and
I'm not showing up and I mean Andy knows
I am but I'm not really showing up but
so you know I get it for Bateman though
it makes sense
he's the voice of Hyundai with you know
sensible compact you know good parking
at the mall you know what I mean like
just the stuff the kind of is a model
and step about when you think about
Bateman what do you think the best thing
yeah yeah sensible and for me I
represent you know North American
know-how and toughness and grit yeah you
know and and hauling capability yeah
yeah I don't know I don't know if you
know this about me yeah but I can haul
oh great you can I look at this guy and
I think this guy can haul